[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans sa aux cadis
spéciale le second tour des municipales
aujourd'hui nous nous intéressons avec
le candidat rudy du villa la commune du
diamant où on le rappelle ça quand même
pas mal voté un pour le premier tour un
taux de participation de 57,35 % ce qui
vous a placé en tête pour au final
finalement rudy duville un duel de
second tour et non pas une triangulaire
alors vous êtes tête de liste du diamant
rassembler la nouvelle dynamique et vous
avez recueilli vous 46e 17% des
suffrages exprimés soit 1339 vote
un duel donc de second tour n'ont pas
une triangulaire puisque vos concurrents
rudy du ville ont fusionné leur liste et
vous devez affronter hull tous ces ex
premier adjoint de gilbert eustache le
maire sortant dont vous êtes vous même
le premier adjoint sortant alors que
tous et qui pèse maintenant 1560 et une
voix
fort du soutien de jambon fort mais
souvent redit du bilan politique tout
n'est pas qu'arithmétique ali ben bongo
jour le cheikh auditeurs de martinique
la première bonjour car oui je bertrand
bonjour la population du diamant donc
effectivement
je suis très heureux que la population
du diamant et reconnu jeudi la liste du
diamant rassembler c'est pour ça que
nous sommes sortis en tête des suffrages
et permettez que je vous remets je
remercie l'ensemble des électeurs et qui
sont venus voter jeudi le 15 mars et
plus singulièrement les 1339 pour le
diamant rassembler
donc effectivement vous avez parlé d'une
alliance effectivement ça peut être une
alliance avec meetic puisque je pense
que c'est ce calcul qualité la base de
travail de ces deux têtes de liste mais
néanmoins je connais les diamants tinois
je suis diamantinoise je respire au
diamant et je sais que les diamants
tinois ne marcheront pas dans cette
combine mais sa annonce un second tour
peut-être cv qui pourrait peut-être se
jouer à quelques dizaines ou centaines
de voix parce que savait le sait comme
une étape de viol c'est comme une étape
de viol donc moi je suis arrivé les
tables du 15 mai en tête je repars avec
la même voilure soit 75 m² pour l'étape
du 28 et tous et à changer son équipage
mais sauf que peut-être qu'il s'attend
pas une mer démontée pour l'arrivée du
28 et je rentrerai premier avec la même
liste au diamant levait le 28 juin
prochain
alors mais que dites vous de cette
alliance justement vous dit peut-être
que c'est le total des voix des deux
candidats qui a peut-être amené à cette
alliance mais en même temps elle est
peut-être pas si contre nature que ça
aux yeux des électrices et électeurs du
diamant aujourd'hui c'est le sujet
principal au diamant tout le monde parle
de 7 cette année un jeu de contre nature
vous avez vous vous estimez qu'il est
contre nature elle et de contre nature
puisque vous avez deux antagonistes et
le premier jour de le premier tour des
élections se déchiraient notamment
monsieur tous et qui vilipendaient aussi
bien le cantou le camp du ville que
l'eau quand mon fort et aujourd'hui les
voir côte à côte
donc tout le monde se pose des questions
parce qu'il ya des personnes qui ont
fait le choix de montfort s'était pas
ils avaient le choix entre du ville et
tous et donc ils ont fait ce choix parce
que monfort a proposé jeudi un programme
à
à une nouvelle approche de la politique
à la diam un renfort qui est un peu
l'héritier de l'équipe de d'yvette galop
c'est ça qui est un moment non est-ce
que je vais présenter les choses comme
ça vous ne rentrez pas dans ces
considérations pas rentrer dans ces
considérations je pense que les
personnes intéressées tôt ou tard feront
savoir qui est 8ème ou pas des électeurs
de galop simplement dans le diamant
rassembler et la nouvelle dynamique
nous nous sommes là pour réconcilier
jeudi la population et c'est pour ça que
nous allons nous battre contre contre
cet accord et c'est pour ça que je vous
dis un accord qui est signé devant
présence d'un avocat
ça veut tout dire qu'il n'ya pas eu
matière à discuter sur la problématique
sargasses ya pas eu matière à discuter
sur la l'écologie de la vie du diamant
il n'y a pas eu matière à discuter du
poste qu vide
ça veut dire que la base de la
négociation était la place du de premier
adjoint et le nombre de personnes à
rentrer ici une liste dont vous avez
deux personnes qui sont là que pour
entre lee mais leur poche et ne pas
regarder l'intérêt de la ville du
diamant alors rapidement rudy duville
donc à la tête de la liste le diamant
rassemblés à l'aune de ce que de ce qui
s'est dit de ce que vous avez échangé
avec la population lors de la campagne
de premier tour avec quelle principal
argument entendez vous convaincre
l'électorat diamantinoise de vous faire
confiance à vous jeunes candidats en âge
on le rappelle qui plus est oui c'est à
dire que il me manquait sans doute voie
pour gagner l'élection le 15 mars
112 oui je pense fortement que convient
d' y est pour beaucoup et
les électeurs n'ont pas eu confiance
pour venir voter donc ça c'est je leur
donne je les comprends mais maintenant
ils ont vu le danger ils ont vu le
danger aujourd'hui j'ai déjà dénombré
énormément de personnes qui sont pas
venus voter le premier tour et ce sont
des personnes qui sont favorables mais
qui vous disent qu'ils viendront pour le
second tour qui sont favorables à la
politique du diamant rassembler et ils
viendront aussi le au second tour là où
j'attire l'attention c'est au milieu les
bills 3 centre france-la conclure 1339
lecture qui ont goûté de roy venir aux
youn le 28
merci rudy du ville d'avoir répondu à
nos questions dans sa ou caddie spécial
second tour des municipales 2020
[Musique]